I'm joined today by Suzanne Kelly she is
author of greening death reclaiming
burial practices and restoring our tie
to the earth she's an independent
scholar
also a farmer in New York's Hudson
Valley beautiful area I've been there
actually and it's a very very very
hipster in some ways sort of like my my
roots so Suzanne let's talk about this
is a really interesting topic burial
practices for humans they sort of
changed over time so paint like the
broad-strokes picture of what the
evolution has been of burial practices
sure well over 150 years ago in the u.s.
we buried our dead in earth friendly
ways you know a simple hole the body was
put in and some kind of a what we would
call today a biodegradable container and
and that was it
people who were buried on the back 40 on
the family farm or in church graveyards
but that all started to change in and
around the 1830s and then what was that
change
well the biggest change was that there
was a rise in in urban populations
collided with new fears around
sanitation this was a time when there
were sanitation reforms happening in
Europe and suddenly in the u.s. the same
thing started to happen there were
diseases that were sweeping through
cities like cholera and yellow fever and
reformers were trying to figure out how
to you know stop people from dying and
getting sick and so they started to
place their attention on really stinky
places in the culture like places of
human waste and of garbage because there
was this belief at that time if
something smelled bad it could actually
cause you like terrible harm it could
actually kill you it was called the
miasma theory and believe it or not some
of those smelly places happened to be
graveyards people like I said were
buried in rural areas out in the back
forty but if not there were in villages
and towns they were they were buried in
church graveyards these were not very
well-kept places they were bodies were
often dug up to make room for other
bodies and so villages and towns and
cities started to place bands on burials
within these locations and they they
began to force the dead outside of to
outside of the village in the town and
the city perimeters this gave rise to
something called the Rural Cemetery
movement which is really nice because
these are beautiful these are beautiful
sent
Terri's almost park-like they grew up in
cities across the budding us we can see
great examples in Boston and Brooklyn
still today but we sometimes forget that
the reason why they actually started at
all was because the dead were sort of
forced there for fear that they could
contaminate us in some way and while
there was some foundation to this
because we didn't really understand how
you know germs affect us or infectious
diseases could really harm us it kind of
snowballed into this idea of the dead
body is something that we have to guard
ourselves against and it sort of made
its way into our burial practices that
was the first thing the second thing was
that the civil war happened and when the
Civil War happens northern soldiers were
dying in the south and great numbers and
suddenly you know people families wanted
burials for for these soldiers for their
sons how to get these bodies back before
decomposition set in prior to this time
embalming even though it had existed for
thousands of years in other parts of the
world was really seen as kind of a fate
worse than death in budding American
culture in European culture it wasn't
something that was done but suddenly
there were new anatomist on the scene
anatomist who were wanting to preserve
cadavers for study and the Union Army
called upon these anatomist for families
who could afford it to have their dead
and bombs to be sent back home for
burial and so you would think that
embalming would have kind of disappeared
when the war ended but it didn't it's
really for two reasons the first is that
Abraham Lincoln when he died his body
was embalmed and it was in bombed and
Riaan bombed that embalm D'Andrea bombed
and traveled across the country in a
railcar so that Americans could actually
gaze upon his body and ultimately gaze
upon this new practice of preservation
some historians have said that it kind
of was symbolic of an overcoming of a
war that had karna donation but as I've
also suggested in my book it was also
representative or symbolic of another
overcoming this preservation you know
this overcoming of nature the other
theater piece of this with embalming was
that the chemical companies and at that
time embalming was mostly made up of
arsenic and other kinds of chemicals
today it's mostly made up of
formaldehyde but the chemical company
has started to set up workshops and
these workshops to be trained in this
new practice of embalming
became our first mortuary schools so the
foundation of our funeral practices in
terms of the funeral industry as we know
it today is foundationally tied to the
development of arterial embalming this
chemical and priming process that is not
required by any state or federal law but
has become common practice so you didn't
really talk much about the influence of
religion in all of this I mean certainly
in many cultures that does play a role
in a lot of these decisions doesn't it
yeah it does and in fact you know if you
look at Jewish burial customs and
Islamic burial customs what we're
calling green burial practices today a
return to the so-called dust to dust
practices the simple burial body of a
body buried inside of some kind of
biodegradable container in kind of a
swift way it's still very much true in
some religious traditions like in
Judaism and in Islam but the burial
practices that came to take shape in the
u.s. were the ones that I just talked
about now embalming and also ultimately
the development of the modern casket and
the burial vault which I can say more
about that trio of practices came to
grow up in and through an industry right
in and through a funeral industry that
was really set apart from from from
religion so the I mean if you think
about the embalming and the chemicals
that are used you think about the wood
or cement or metal or whatever might
also be used to create the burial casket
or a container I don't know of what the
sort of more general umbrella term would
be when you think about all of those
things is cremation really the
eco-friendly thing well that's a great
question I mean when we look at the the
when green barrel advocates look at the
the toxic qualities as you talked about
of the standard American funeral which
includes that trio of practices
embalming the modern casket and the
burial vault the burial vaults as as we
know or maybe we don't know is made is
usually made up of reinforced concrete
sometimes it's made up of plastic
sometimes it's made up of asphalt which
we know is a semi solid form of
petroleum all of which is put in the
ground embalming fluid is a well known
carcinogen that actually is
biodegradable but does pose a threat to
worker health and then of course there's
the modern casket metals
treated hardwoods in some studies of the
soil in silt loam in the in cemeteries
there's been shown to be elevated levels
of things like zinc and cobalt and lead
so all of that is here so yeah you would
think that cremation is is is much
better and I would think that if you I
think that if you talk to most green
burial advocates free cremation is
considered to be the second most
environmentally sound way of disposing
of the dead if you look at the green
burial grounds that have emerged over
the last 20 years in the US and there's
roughly about 150 all of them pretty
much except internment of cremated
remains
if cremation is less than ideal it's
only because anytime you burn something
you pose a threat to soil water and air
and in the u.s. we haven't done such a
great job like they have been doing in
parts of Europe of placing filters on
Crematory is to filter out things like
dioxins and iran's and believe it or not
mercury from dental fillings so you know
we have a little bit of a ways to go
with regard to to those tibet so what
would be sort of at the top of the list
the green dream I guess for burial well
if you're talking simply in terms of
sustainability and lack of pollution
you know simple simple earth burial is
the the least toxic toxic and least
polluting and most sustainable way of
caring for the dead right now that we
have and you know green burial as it
exists in the u.s. right now is whole
body earth burial as I said the use of a
biodegradable container a body is buried
about three and a half four feet deep
all the soil that's taken out of the
ground is put back in the the a burial
mound is typically made and then that
man eventually settles over time and at
its most basic that's what we're seeing
in green burial grounds across the US
but some marine burial grounds actually
state take it a step further and are
focused on the conservation preservation
and restoration of land so if we're
interested if people are interested
really in sustainability and an
environmentalism at that level there is
an effort to really partner with the
land to care for the land and how does
that work well I mean I I know that I've
seen one yeah idea of you can be turned
into a tree but really what it looked
like was that a tree is planted and the
sort of root system will develop around
the body you're not really being turned
into a tree I mean it's sort of a
romanticized way of saying it I think
right yeah that is a product that's on
the market right now but but what I'm
talking about is actually um it's
actually tying the fact of human death
to actually create conservation areas
preservation areas that are used both as
cemeteries but also land that it's cared
for in perpetuity so what we see the
first Green burial ground that opened in
the u.s. called Ramsey Creek in
Westminster South Carolina you know was
open with with that mission with that
purpose of protecting not just the lands
where the burials are happening say that
20 some-odd acres were there burying
bodies but the hundreds of acres that
are surrounding that area some green
burial grounds were that big that can be
used as open space as park space as wild
space for people to enjoy again in
perpetuity we're in all of this in terms
of sustainability does cryopreservation
fit I'm assuming it's not particularly
environmentally friendly particularly
given all of the energy resources that
are required to run those facilities
exactly there is some skepticism by some
green burial advocates that that we have
to look at those at the energy that's
that's put in to some of these so-called
new technologies that are that are that
are on the market or wanting to be on
the market and that certainly would
would fit into one of them I would say
that you know at the purest level green
advocate green burial advocates are
really interested in terms of my own
research and my own on-the-ground work
of developing a green burial ground in
my own community you know really see
this sort of return to the past with a
new environmental consciousness is the
way to go as opposed to these new
technologies that are developing so
everything we've been talking about I
mean this gets back to if this is
interesting to anybody who's listening
or to are watching the interview this
relates to basically estate planning and
you're one one's will right I mean this
is how somebody would have to put into
place a plan if this was appealing to
them yeah you know that's it that's a
great point
and I don't know that one would actually
have to put it into their will they
would have to talk to their you know
their elder law attorney or their estate
planner with respect to that but I think
that what we're seeing with green burial
especially
there are not so many green burial
grounds that exist in the US right now
is that pre-planning is really important
we know that when someone dies there's
sort of a rush to figure out what's
going to happen and you know very often
the funeral machine kind of takes over
and so if people really want to have an
earth burial if they're really
interested in returning to a green
burial ground you know planning ahead
telling your family having the
conversation with your family or with
your attorney is really really important
part of this even with your funeral
director if you're in a state where a
funeral director is required we've been
speaking about the book
greening death reclaiming burial
practices and restoring our tie to the
earth with the book's author Suzanne
Kelly very very interesting work thanks
for sharing it with us thank you